I'll be going read my name goodbye
welcome back to some more happy will
that scowl alright fine until you
arrived we got some problems here that
barrel no shut up back there in the fast
we lived in harmony with the back what
honey shut up I told you well what's
going on here ha I got a new what are
you doing you're not my son
I grew up super fast shut up like that
god dammit well you're better son than I
ever had let's go come on Oh son what
are you doing on my face let's go son
don't die it's better it's undeniable
shed nevermind alright front flap
whatever get mom oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh no I feel like I'm not gonna make
this dump I made it Brow's get the [ __ ]
out barrels [ __ ] about us
goddamnit what the hell happened eh
alright come with us celebration dad
alright fine Jason skies there but dad
so gay sure you keep saying that I'll go
over here all right nice big Marsh big
boys be shut Nate Murphy
alright you can't stay there battle get
the [ __ ] out I needs a jump all right I
did it anyway [ __ ] your barrel don't
think you can stop me
alright let's go now ah alright alright
ah I never thought you could come but
never
if pit pie is here I'm paired up I know
you're like I will never realize my
socks were so pretty
let me just sit down thanks for playing
do you ever see a barrel shove them no
mercy kill them kill them on awesome
that [ __ ] the best man
alright let's go honey that just let me
grab down boobies [ __ ] yeah
you're not a unicorn - okay your your
Akash J says Christ had a you're
scratching my vagina well don't you like
it add a vector out shed it in I checked
myself and face it's pretty impressive
thought every day you kick yourself in
the face and scratch fever woman's
vagina
my mama mama - kiss the [ __ ] out of ya
ha I don't care oh no no no no I did my
Jesus Jill god dammit
oh sorry out it god damn that birds aw
[ __ ] I think I died here we go three
times a boobie hell that should be good
alright let's go honey I was just
telling baby don't go hello handsome
are you dumb wha oh yeah oh yeah bit of
shut-eye ambition just how the hell did
this happen
what why didn't L grab the box and arrow
keys to move what's the point of this no
boyfriend now shaking no grandpa no
playing no bullying no target is a jerk
no sleeping no look at fat [ __ ] it's
fun
no drugs no nothing
that's a good mom right there
okay fatality finish hi hey that's
awesome
hold on
press ctrl grab the hammer holiday oh
hello there Gramps how you doing alright
I'll come here come here grabs let me
love you tonight and I'll make you feel
alright I do anything I want to grab
your take average getting good is good I
first get I first good I don't worry
about it what are you doing in this guy
don't worry about it uh bit too shed
bitter beat dish I came no it's great
that was great grabs what seriously done
more like ferry awfully dull mom all
right
oh shut up shut up shut up
hello why didn't the hell it I'm free
ah [ __ ] nevermind nevermind I'll scratch
my badge
oh [ __ ] somewhere like here we go again
rocket think I shut up oh no my helmet -
are you later helmet got a rocket to fly
on
hell yeah oh shut right in my pin is
alright
seriously don't move
call Matt alright let's try some bloody
Crashers alright
stop doing that baby you're gonna get
yourself killed
alright that's a good start
well what am i doing [ __ ] fetus doing
yoga and [ __ ] what are you doing back
there
free free free free free free stylish
rock Amaka
oh [ __ ] tellenson still dancin still
dancin never stop that I'd known stop
but the babies yeah yeah oh yeah
hey we go have a go have a gap well she
had to be sacrificed
don't worry about it no one cares about
Lisa okay
holy [ __ ] shut fatality well don't move
alright I'm not moving
whoa fatality I keep getting this
they're awesome
alright it's you and me baby ah [ __ ]
come on that intro nerves it's you and
me baby baby can you stop dying please
alright thank you
what is this Pete I got fate all right
baby I don't need a leg don't worry
about it baby mama mom I'm scared shut
up
all right front flip [ __ ] yeah baby
baby what are you doing now baby don't
make me choke you don't worry about it
baby oh [ __ ] don't worry about it baby
go away oh [ __ ] head shot go baby make
me proud
ah [ __ ] you BAE well everybody in the
power to put your hands up and party
with my dead baby breath [ __ ] yeah party
all night long
party on Islay gonna party with my gay
baby baby heads up baby girl baby ah
everybody now say ayo ayo ayo ayo come
on I'm a CL mother [ __ ] Adama
what what happened there what the hell
is she doing
haha oh you [ __ ] flies on that thing
look at them legs
what don't worry about it baby I'll get
you somewhere safe another big day
Oh a mine run let's go what is that what
the [ __ ] is this god damn it Lisa they
say I could have made it you know go
back come back
Wow - gnarly I'm a man
Turner one does not simply fly this baby
tomorrow we can make it we can make it
we [ __ ] made it
that's how we roll in pitter-patter even
though there's no such thing I think
that's enough happy wheels for me today
anyway like impaired if you enjoy this
guy come with red today and I'll see you
next episode
on whatever I make stay awesome bread
you know I love you in a phone so
beautiful I don't even know where to
begin
we got to change the color on that thing
Alex set a ginger mix of ginger and all
righty
nice more beautiful ice MA